hey guys decided to do a real quick
breakdown for next week's season finale
promo of American Horror Story so if you
haven't seen it yet I've left a link in
the description below so check it out
and come right on back also if you don't
want potential spoilers steer clear the
first image we see our hands bursting
out of the ground near what appears to
be a church at first glance I thought
these were zombies but they're actually
human the one in the middle even has
gloves on and you know who almost always
wears gloves
Myrtle which leaves me to believe this
shot happens shortly after the bombs
have dropped and this is Cordelia
Madison and Myrtle who have survived the
blast
Cordelia says this is a battle between
good and evil well duh and we get this
recycled shot of Brock way back from
episode three Mallory asks how they're
gonna stop a thousand nuclear bombs as
me tells members of the Church of Satan
to bow down before their king we also
get this super quick shot of Michael
Langdon appearing to cast a spell on
Madison Venable holds her cocaine bowl
likely on her way to the safety of
outpost 3 another recycled shot of
Cordelia fainting hinting that this
episode will conclude with her death
Coco says there must be another way
which is likely referring to Cordelia
having to transfer her power to Mallory
and killing herself in the process Dinah
appears before the other witches and
Michael says something about a witch
fight Dinah's betrayal will likely be
revealed here an air raid siren
overlooking Los Angeles here hints that
we'll see the destruction from a
different vantage point and Jessica
Lange is back and doesn't seem to be
doing well with her son as Cordelia
exclaims in order to save the world
they will have to watch it burn we get
this creepy ass image of Michael who
looks like he's just fought off some
witches as Mallory descends into water
but my guess is that she's holding on to
something of Michaels which will allow
her to go back in time and stop him this
is her performing that time-travel which
we saw her fail at last episode this
shot here is oddly similar to when
Vivien Harmon tried to kill Michael in
the Murder House episode Cordelia blow
some dust which looks like the same
thing Madison did to violet to make her
see the truth about Tate but could this
be how Cordelia makes Dino Mallory and
Coco forget who they are that's it for
this promo breakdown I promised you it
would be quick I'll be back here next
Thursday with my full episode 10
breakdown and you can see everything I
got wrong make sure to LIKE and
and if you haven't checked out my other
videos give them a look stay tuned